Well, tensions
over the war
broke out at a meeting of Black
Sea nations earlier in Turkey.
Have a look at this.
Russian delegates
tore down the Ukrainian flag
and on the back of that,
Ukrainian delegate punched him
on social media.
The Ukrainian
lawmaker wrote,
Paws off our flag, paws off Ukraine.
And, well, some words
I'm not going to repeat here.
Earlier, scuffles broke out
when Ukrainians
tried to shout over a Russian speaker
Are Russia and US relations is, quote,
on the verge of an open armed conflict.
Yes.
According to Russia's deputy
foreign minister,
as reported by the country's state media,
at least, Sergei
Ryabkov accused
the US of being, quote,
a direct party to the Ukrainian conflict.
But he qualified.
What were these
ominous comments
saying that Moscow
is working
to make sure
an armed conflict with Washington
doesn't happen
Let's find out what the US
is saying about this.
CNN's Oren Liebermann is at the Pentagon.
What's been the U.S. response?
All right.
Well, this is the sort of statement
from Russia
and from the Kremlin
that fits into Russia's
narrative of the US
being part of the war
in Ukraine, an accusation
Russia has repeatedly made, in fact,
with that drone explosion
we saw over
the Kremlin just several days ago,
it was the Kremlin saying that Russia
that the US dictated
to Ukraine to carry out such an attack.
So this fits into that narrative.
More importantly,
we have seen statements
like this, hyperbolic statements
about how bad relations are
from Russia before.
In fact, several years ago,
while I was reporting in Moscow,
Russia came out and said that relations
between the U.S.
and Russia, between Washington
and Moscow were the worst
they've ever been.
Clearly,
we have seen them get far worse
in the last several years,
especially the last several months.
But it also fits into Russia's narrative
that Russia is the one trying to uphold
international law
and justice throughout the world.
And it's the US
that's the one that's endangering this.
So from Russia's perspective,
this neatly fits into their narrative
about how it's Russia
trying to uphold the global order
and the US threatening it.
I haven't seen a response
specifically to this from the U.S.,
but the U.S.
likely to point out in response
that it's Russia
that invaded Ukraine and Russia
that's threatening the order
the world order that's been sustained
ever since pretty much the end of
of World War Two.
So in this accusation
from Russia that the U.S.
and Russia are close
to armed conflict, again,
you see the narrative
that Russia is trying
to put out there, blaming
the US for the war in Ukraine,
blaming the U.S.
for being involved in
and a direct party to that war.
And Russia painting itself as the one
trying to fix the global order and
fix the situation
or Lehman's.
That depends again for you folks.
Thank you.
Well, we're
also seeing signs of deepening cracks
in Russia's war machine.
The head of
what is the private military group
evolved into issuing a stunning rebuke
today,
a public rebuke against Vladimir
Putin's military
He posted a grim video
showing the bodies of fighters
who he says died
because they are not
getting the ammunition
that they need to fight.
And we've got to warn you,
although this clip is blurred,
its content is disturbing.
But that was quite an issue of
these men here
who died today, or Wagner PMC.
Their blood is still fresh
Film, all of them
well ahead of Wagner,
also drawing a line in the sand,
announcing that he will pull his forces
out of parliament.
In Ukraine next week.
Now, the Ukrainian military
is calling this
a possible turning point in
what is that
brutal battle in eastern Ukraine.
That battle, of course,
has been raging for months,
producing heavy casualties
with little progress for either side.